I get out of the car and this policeman
stops I was wearing a bleach hoodie that
day and he gets out of the car and he's
like bro you caught up on
bleach you can't do that you cannot just
do that there needs to be a version of
the horn on a car that says are you
caught a
bumble hello I'm Le Al Mar and I'm Leah
president and I'm Nick Freedman and this
is crunchy roll presents the anime
[Music]
effect
and we're just going to beat on Nick for
a little
bit why were you paying attening me
we're a brand new podcast breaking down
the anime and pop culture news you care
about and revealing just how powerful
the anime effect really is every week
we'll be discussing anime topics that
are important to us fans like how to
find your new favorite anime based on
moments and pop culture you already love
and will help you find your new favorite
genre Mecca perhaps and we're inviting
guests we know you'll recognize to join
in on the discussion
whether you're a dedicated anime fan or
have only checked out a few shows we
want you to experience the anime effect
tune in the crunchy roll presents the
anime effect every Friday starting
February 16th and you can watch full
episodes on crunchy roll the crunchy
roll YouTube channel let me do that
again YouTube
channel YouTube poop you can watch full
episodes on Crunchyroll or on the
Crunchyroll YouTube channel or just
listen wherever you get your podcast you
can find all those links in the show
notes yeah I think we need to do one
more
little no that's
it we got it